>> Tucker: FOR CENTURIES,
FREEDOM OF SPEECH HAS BEEN
AMERICA'S SIGNATURE RIGHT,
THAT'S WHAT SETS US APART FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES, EVEN RELATIVELY
FREE COUNTRIES.
CERTAINLY THE REST OF EUROPE AND
CANADA, BUT COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE
INTERESTED IN ALL.
A NEW SURVEY BY GALLUP FINDS
THAT 53% OF COLLEGE STUDENTS SAY
HAVING A DIVERSE AND INCLUSIVE
SOCIETY IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
PROTECTING FREE SPEECH.
AND COULTER IS AN AUTHOR AND
COLUMNIST AND A HAWK ON FREE
SPEECH.
THANKS FOR VISITING WITH US.
YOU CAN'T HAVE A DIVERSE OF AN
INCLUSIVE COUNTRY AND KEEP THE
FIRST AMENDMENT?
>> OF COURSE YOU CAN COME OUT
WE'VE HAD IT FOR A FEW HUNDRED
YEARS.
WHAT WAS STRANGE ABOUT THIS
SURVEY, WHICH I NOTICED
IMMEDIATELY WHEN IT LANDED IN MY
INBOX, IT WAS ODD THAT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" PRESENTED
IT AS WELL, WE'VE COVERED ALL
THE BASES, THE ONLY BREAKDOWN IN
AGE, BREAKDOWNS IN POLITICAL
PARTY, THE ONLY ETHNIC BREAKDOWN
WAS BLACK-AND-WHITE AMERICANS.
DID THEY THINK WE'RE LIVING IN
THE 1950s?
WHAT IS STRIKING IS THIS IS OF
COURSE, ANOTHER PROBLEM OF
IMMIGRATION.
HISPANICS AND ASIANS,
OVERWHELMINGLY, WHETHER IT'S THE
RESEARCH CENTER, ALL KINDS OF
SURVEYS DONE OVER THE YEARS,
SHOW THAT WHITE AND BLACK
AMERICANS OVERWHELMINGLY SUPPORT
BOTH FREE SPEECH AND GUN RIGHTS
AND YOU HAVE ALMOST THE REVERSE
PERCENTAGES WITH IMMIGRANTS.
THIS IDEA THAT PEOPLE COME TO
OUR COUNTRY AND SUDDENLY THINK,
I UNDERSTAND, YOU HAVE A RIGHT
TO SPEAK EVEN IF I DISAGREE WITH
YOU AND EVEN IF YOUR QUOTING THE
PROPHET MOHAMMED, DOESN'T WORK
THAT WAY.
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING AT PLACES
LIKE BERKELEY, ASIAN STUDENTS
ALONE ARE 46%, THAT'S MORE THAN
BLACK AND WHITE AMERICANS
COMBINED.
THAT'S WHY YOU'RE GETTING THE
BIGGEST ATTACKS ON FREE SPEECH
AT PLACES LIKE BERKELEY.
>> Tucker: SO IT'S NOT A LEFT
RIGHT THING AS MUCH AS IT IS A
NEW ARRIVAL VERSUS BORN HEAR A
THING, WHY WOULDN'T WE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO INCULCATE
OUR BELIEFS AND UNDERSTANDINGS
OF OUR RIGHTS AND CONSTITUTION
OF PEOPLE WHO JUST GOT HERE?
>> EVEN AMONG 11TH GENERATION
AMERICANS, THESE PEOPLE CALLED
LIBERALS AND THEIR AS OPPOSED TO
OUR FUNDAMENTAL FREEDOMS AS THE
NEWCOMERS ARE.
STAUNCH ON THE ISSUE OF FREE
SPEECH, LOSING A LOT OF THEIR
DONORS I MIGHT ADD.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT THE ACLU
WOULD HAVE AN OPINION ON THE
IMPORTATION OF PEOPLE ADAMANTLY
OPPOSED TO THE MISSION STATEMENT
IN THEIR CHARTER.
WE ARE LOOKING AT THE DEATH OF
AMERICA IS A FUNDAMENTAL
FREEDOMS AS YOU SAID IN YOUR
INTRODUCTION, EVEN ENGLAND
DOESN'T HAVE FREE SPEECH.
FOR AMERICA, BOTH
FIRST AMENDMENT AND
SECOND AMENDMENT AS THIS NEW
GENERATION OF NON-AMERICANS.
>> Tucker: WHY ARE
INCORPORATIONS EMBEDDING THIS?
KROGER ANNOUNCED THEY WOULD NO
LONGER STOCK MAGAZINES OF IMAGES
WITH ASSAULT WEAPONS, SCARY
LOOKING GUNS ARE NO LONGER
ALLOWED AND PHOTOGRAPHS AND
KROGER.
SINCE WHEN ARE COMPANIES SORT OF
PILING ON SPEECH RESTRICTIONS
HERE?
>> IT'S BEEN AT LEAST SINCE
TRUMP HAS COME ALONG, MAY BE
BEFORE THEN, BUT I RETURN TO MY
REFRAIN, I DON'T CARE WHAT YOUR
OPINION IS ON FREE SPEECH OR
GUNS OR ANYTHING ELSE, BUT
PLEASE STOP PRETENDING YOU'RE A
REBEL, PLEASE STOP ATTENDING OR
FIGHTING THE MAN WHEN YOU ARE
LOCKSTEP WITH CORPORATE AMERICA.
THESE NEW RADICALS WE HAVE, THE
RESISTANCE, THEY'LL CHECK WITH
CORPORATE AMERICA, APPLE AND
TWITTER, FACEBOOK AND THEIR
PROFESSORS TO ASK IF THEY CAN
WEAR A QUESTION AUTHORITY
T-SHIRT.
WOULD THAT BE OKAY?
>> Tucker: HAS THERE EVER BEEN
A MORE OBEDIENT CADRE OF ROBOTS
THAN COLLEGE STUDENTS?
IS ANYONE BRAVE?
IS ANYBODY GIVING THE FINGER TO